it is our constant companion influencing
many aspects of our culture thoughts and
being ever-present in design art music
science technology religion but what is
the moon it depends who you ask the
ancient Mesopotamians would speak of
nana the god of the moon and creator of
all things while the present-day
cosmologists might describe the
stabilizing influence of our earth's
tilt and most of his picture the moon is
being closer than it actually is
mm-my just squeezed for a textbook
strangely the Sun is 400 times further
away from the earth in the moon and is
400 times its size this means that
viewed from the earth they appear to be
exactly the same size science fiction
writer Isaac Asimov described this
natural quirk as the most unlikely
coincidence imaginable these
correlations didn't go unnoticed by
early stargazing cultures notably a
hundred eight is an specious number for
Hindus who count a hundred and eight
marma points or sacred places in the
body many believe the moon affects our
bodies we know its cushion plant affects
the tides and we are organic creatures
made largely a water who evolved in an
ecosystem reliant on this celestial
neighbor what about the moon's effect on
our states of minds the word lunacy is
derived from the latin word lunatic us
winning moon stroke statistics do show
consistent rising crime rates around the
full moon scientists prefer to attribute
this to convenient light levels for the
plying of nefarious activity and it is
not only our minds in question the
perceived connection between fertility
and the cycles of the moon goes back a
long time perhaps that's just because
the lunar and menstrual cycles correlate
so closely in the ancient world the moon
was generally personified as male the
shift to female deities and ideas
happening Maurice
relatively speaking if the moon is
female there has been no shortage of
historical characters trying to fathom
her mysteries the harness this elusive
beacon of the natural world
so it's nice to hear NASA has just
announced an initiative to put a woman
on the moon by 2024 aptly named Artemis
after Greek god Apollo swim sister and
the moons many phases continued with
some seeing them as a harbinger of doom
the Murray people called the moon Hina
the man-eater who was the bringer of
death then there's a melancholic
reflective moon around the turn of the
18th century as we adjusted to the brave
new world of science and discovery
artists became increasingly focused on
our place in the natural world paintings
from the likes of Caspar David Friedrich
and Joseph Wright of Derby turned to the
moon as a central theme often with small
human figures their backs to the viewer
in quiet reflection finally in July 1969
we successfully landed two men on the
moon and we discovered what she'd been
silently gazing upon for this time so
what is the moon male/female a
life-support system or a bringer of
death inducer of madness a conspiracy a
symbol of peace what if it's all these
things embodying all the light and
shared of human experience it seems the
moon is whatever we choose to see the
constant reflection of us thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
click the bail to receive notifications
for new videos see you again soon